robert spencer the more moderate sunni
arab states that thanks to donald trump
have relations with israel
are panicked over the united states
moving
away from them and into the shia camp
with iran
it seems and i think they're right
they're being
abandoned along with the more moderate
sunnis who want peace with each other
with israel and the united states
and they're all by themselves while
israel crawls back into bed
with the radicals in tehran are these
more moderate sunni states
justified in their worrisome behavior
now
they absolutely are barry as a matter of
fact the recent conflict between hamas
and israel broke out in large part
because hamas was trying
to bring the states that had made
pragmatic alliances with israel
back into line supporting the
palestinian jihad
the states that made alliances with
israel and the abraham
accords did so in large part because
israel
and these states share a common threat
and that is
iran bahrain for example is considered
by the islamic republic of iran
to be the 15th province of the islamic
republic of iran so bahrain has every
reason
to ally with other states that are
threatened by iran so does the uae
so does saudi arabia for that matter
although it did not officially enter the
abraham accords
so one paradoxical effect of the biden
administration's cozying up to
iran will be actually to strengthen the
abraham accords
because these states will understand
that these pragmatic alliances that they
made with israel are needed more than
ever
and other states will see that they need
them as well